on peut imaginer l'étonnement du
spéléologue retrouvant brutalement la
lumière après quarante six heures
d'incertitude 15h la civière sort enfin
du puits de vaud vaugier entouré d'une
armée de spéléologues bénévoles
qu'est ce que vous dites de ceux de
sauvetage dernière tyrolienne presque un
jeu d'enfant
ultime segment d'une remontée qui aura
duré plus de 13 heures le spéléologue
âgé d'une cinquantaine d'années dit
souffrir du bassin il était conscient à
l'arrivée c'est bien passé sous les en
arrivons donc on met longtemps
c'est bien pour nous c'est un collègue
la nuit dernière pourtant le doute était
encore permis à plusieurs reprises les
sauveteurs avaient dû s'arrêter pour
élargir les galeries au perforateur et
au burin différent à chaque fois de
quelques heures la sortie sur certains
passages étroits de la cavité où on
pourrait évacuer la civière en la
mettant sur le côté les douleurs
ressenties par la victime nous empêche
de le faire ce qui nous obligera à
grandir plus les passages la centaine de
spéléologues venus du doubs et des
départements voisins ainsi que les
pompiers n'avaient pas connu pareille
secours depuis plusieurs années le puits
de vaud vaugier réputé difficile a
compliqué la tâche
ce qui est dur c'est le fait de ne pas
savoir quand ça va se finir savoir
attendre le courant d'air froid et du
grand air
donc un succès collectif saluée par le
sous préfet du doubs moi j'ai rien
donner du tout j'ai simplement quelques
heures de sommeil en retard mais c'est
pas grave moi j'ai pas la face il j'ai
pas la fatigue dans les muscles dans les
jambes j'ai la grande satisfaction de
partager avec mon coeur toute la joie
qu'ils auront leur le spéléologue
dijonnais a été évacué très vite vers
l'hôpital de besançon
à 19 heures les derniers sauveteurs
entamé à leur tour une lente et
fastidieuse remonter